In Parliament
affects our environment in so many ways and affects how we respond to,
or if we bother responding to,
climate change at all or climate breakdown.
Um,
it affects the natural world through fishing policy,
trade policy, it governs all our emissions, deforestation,
agriculture, biodiversity, pesticides.
Um, all of these different policy areas come from the EU.
And one of the big issues of the EU
is that there are so many lobbyists there.
They have such access compared to citizens, to, um,
both to, I suppose,
the, uh,
permanent staff in the EU institutions and also the parliamentarians.
Um, and it is vital that we elect people who take this seriously,
who don't particularly want to live in a world, uh,
where you can't rely on seasons
and where the coast has moved inland by whatever,
hundred meters, um,
and where it's difficult to get food to eat, uh,
in, because areas are in such big drought.
Um,
so we need to make sure that we are electing people
who are taking climate seriously
and actually using climate action to improve people's lives.
Like, there's,
you know, it's often used by people.
People say, oh, well,
you know this client,
and then they'll pick, they'll pick something kinda silly.
They'll pick a carbon tax and they'll say,
well,
this is the reason we shouldn't take any action on environment at all.
Which is ridiculous, because that would be like saying, if.
Whatever, if it's a housing policy,
Didn't work, if you like.
Then we should have no housing policy whatsoever,
as opposed to it needs to be better.
So we need climate action on climate and environment
that takes into account all of society's needs
and is used as a way to make things better
and to address existing inequalities.
As opposed to just, um,
making money for companies in these,
like, phony,
baloney carbon credit schemes or stuff like that.